สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
โอเคมาเจอกันอีกแล้วใช่ในอ่า beginner  4
นะคะ beginner  4 แล้วเนาะอืใช่ๆวันนี้
ที่เรามาคุย
กันเป็นวันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันพุธค่ะวันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
อืมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
อืมกี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้ 14
น 43 นทีค่ะ 43 นาที
อื 13 นาทีแล้วนั่นแหละครูเลียมกินข้าว
หรือยังกินข้าวเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะอืยังรู้
สึกอิ่มอยู่เลยค่ะโอกินนานแล้วใช่มั้ยคะ
กินประมาณตอน 13:00 นค่ะคุณูปาออกินตอน
13:00 นยังอิ่มอยู่เลยยังไม่หิวกินเยอะ
มากกินเยอะมากอาหารไทยอร่อยค่ะอร่อยใช่ๆ
แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะคะกินข้าวหรือยังครูฟ้า
เนี่ยกินข้าวแล้วค่ะครูเรียมว่ากิน
บาร์บีคิวไปค่ะ
อืมบาร์บีคิวนะคะนักเรียนก็จะมีหมูใช่มย
มีไก่นะคะแล้วก็มีหนังไก่ใช่มยไก่และหนัง
ไก่มีหัวใจไก่ด้วยนะอร่อยมากนะเดี๋ยวเปิด
ให้ดู
บาร์บีคิวนิมเข้าใจว่าบาร์บีคิวมี
สับปะรดมีมะเขือเทศเออมันเค้าเรียก
บาร์บีคิวมั้อ่ะใช่มยอ๋อแบบไทยบาร์บีคิว
อะไรอย่างงี้
หรอใช่เอ่อแป๊บนึงนะอันเนี้ยนักเรียนอาจ
จะรู้สึกว่าอีครูฟ้ากินอะไรนะคะหัวใจไก่
ค่ะครูเลียม
[เพลง]
โอ้โหนี่อืหัว
ใจหัวใจไก่หัวใจไก่อร่อยนะคะอร่อยอออือ
ชอบครูฟ้าชอบกินหรอชอบค่ะชอบค่ะคือครูฟ้า
เคยกินตอนเรียน University นะคะว่าเมื่อ
ก่อนก็ไม่กินแต่เพื่อนบอกอร่อยแล้วก็เลย
ลองหัวใจไก่อ่ะนะอร่อยได้ยังไงก็เลยลอง
กินนะคะอร่อยจริงๆหรอใช่คูิมริมนึกถึง
เรื่องนี้เลยเรื่องที่จะเล่าวันนี้อะไรคะ
เพราะริมก็ไม่คิดว่าจะมีใครแบบกินหัวใจคน
อื่นนั่นน่ะสิทำไมเราถึงไปอยากอยากจะกิน
หัวใจคะเท่าไหร่เท่าไรครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องถาม
ครูฟ้าไงครูฟ้าบอกว่าอร่อย
อร่อยบาร์บีคิวด้วยอร่อยมากทำไมอ่ะครู
เรียมเรื่องที่ครูเรียมจะเล่าเนี่ย
กินหัวใจไก่เหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะแต่เป็นหัวใจ
สักต์บางอย่างหัวใจของสัตว์อือแต่ไม่ใช่
ไก่หมูแต่ไม่ใช่ไก่เดี๋ยวยังไม่ยังไม่บอก
ดีกว่าโอเคยังไม่บอกก็ได้เดี๋ยวเพราะว่า
เรื่องที่เรียมจะเล่าวันเนี้ยเกี่ยวกับ
ลิงตัวนึงที่ฉลาดมาก
อืลิงนะคะนักเรียนลิงนะคะเหมือนมั้ยลิเออ
เหมือนหรือเปล่านะลิ่งนักเรียนน่าจะรู้
จักอยู่แล้วกินกล้วยใช่มยลิงกินกล้วยแล้ว
ก็ปีนต้นไม้ใช่ลิงอืนะคะเกี่ยวกับลิงเหรอ
คะใช่ลิงที่ฉลาดมากเอ้าลิงเนี่ยสปีชี
เดียวกับมนุษย์ใช่มเอ่อลิงสปีชีเดียวกับ
คนใช่มั้ยคะโฮโมเซเปียนอะไรพวกเนี้ยเป็น
ลิงก็ต้องฉลาด IQ  EQ ดีใช่มยใช่ๆๆอืแล้ว
ก็เป็นลิงตัวนึงที่อยู่ในป่าอือยู่ในป่า
ด้วยครูเหรียมใช่ลิงก็ต้องอยู่ในป่านะคะ
อยู่ในป่าเออใช่ๆอแล้วทีนี้ในป่าเนี่ยเขา
ก็จะมีเหมือนแม่น้ำ
อืใช่ในปลาก็มีแม่น้ำแม่
น้ำตรงนี้ก็มีต้นไม้เยอะๆก็จะเป็นป่าตรง
นี้ก็จะมีต้นไม้เยอะๆก็เป็นป่าเหมือนกัน
แต่ก็จะมีแม่น้ำที่ไหลผ่านมา
อืก็อยู่ที่
นี่ลิงอยู่ในป่าหรอลิงก็อยู่ในป่าอยู่บน
ต้นไม้กินกล้วยกินอะไรนะคะอ่าใช่ค่ะใช่อื
เสร็จแล้วแต่ว่าทุกๆวันตอนเช้าที่พระ
อาทิตย์ขึ้นตื๊ดๆๆพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นแล้วเรา
ก็จะตื่นขึ้นมาใช่มยคะใช่ลิกก็จะออกมาจาก
ป่าทำไมคะแล้วก็ข้ามแม่น้ำออกมาหาหากล้วย
กินอ๋อหากล้วยหาอาหารกินอืตอนเช้าลิงก็จะ
ออกมานะคะอืใช่ลิงก็จะข้ามแม่
น้ำข้ามแม่น้ำมาว่ายน้ำเหรอเคยเห็นลิง
ว่ายน้ำมั้ยนั่นน่ะสิคิดลิงว่ายน้ำ
หรอลิงว่ายน้ำได้หรอไม่นะลิงว่ายน้ำไม่
ได้ใช่มยไม่แต่ว่าเล่นน้ำได้แต่ไม่ไม่ได้
ว่ายน้ำไม่ว่ายน้ำค่ะไม่ว่ายน้ำอือืใช่
ลิงเนี่ยเอ๊แล้วลิงเ้าจะข้ามแม่น้ำมาได้
ยังไง
อืทำยังไงคะก็ต้องมีหิน
อ่าหินนะคะครูเรียมครูเรียมมีหินหรือ
เปล่านี่หิน
อือันนี้แบบนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นหินกี่
ก้อน 1  2  3  4  5 ครูฟ้าเห็น 5 ก้อนอ๋อ
หิน 5 ก้อนริมันอาจจะมี 6 ก็ได้นะไม่รู้
แต่เห็น 5 ใช่มั้ยแต่เห็น 5 ก้อนใช่แล้ว
ก็มีหินแบบนี้อีกนะอืมอันนี้เค้าเรียก
อะไรคะแบ
แบนหินแบนๆนะคะหรือว่าแผ่นหินใช่มั้ยแผ่น
หินอืใช่เป็นแผ่นหินนะคะ
อืถ้าเกิดเป็นแบบเนี้ยเราก็จะเรียกว่า
แผ่นหินอันนี้ 1 แผ่นอื 1 แผ่นอือแต่ถ้า
เกิดมันเป็นกลมๆใช่มยกลมๆเราก็จะเรียกว่า
ก้อนก้อนหินอืมก้อนหินอืแผ่นหินอืนั่น
แหละแล้วทีนี้ลิงตัวนี้ก็เลยใช้แผ่นหิน
ใช่มยใช่ลิงนี่ไงลิงใช้ก้อนหินเนี่ยวาง
วางๆาๆๆาเพื่อที่จะเดินข้ามแม่น้ำใช่แล้ว
อืเอาก้อนหินแล้วก็แผ่นหินวางๆาๆาแล้วก็
เดินข้ามแม่น้ำลิงก็เดินโอ้ฉลาดมากีกใช่
ฉลาดมากาด
มากพอมาหากล้วยกินเสร็จแล้วถึงตอนเย็นที่
พระอาทิตย์ตกตอนเย็นและกลับบ้านมั้ยก็จะ
กลับกลับบ้านอือๆๆกลับบ้านไปนอนในป่าอือ
ได้อ่าทุกๆวันค่ะครูปาคือทุกวันก็เป็นแบบ
นี้ทุกวันใช่มั้ยคะครูเรี่มใช่ค่ะๆอืแล้ว
มีแต่ว่าในป่าเนี่ยไม่ได้มีแค่ลิงตัว
เดียวใช่มั้ยคะครูปามีอะไรอีกคะในป่าเค้า
ก็จะมีสัตว์อื่นๆอีกเยอะมากในป่า
ก็มีทั้งอะไรอ่ะมีนกมั้ยอืมก็จะมีนกมีมี
งูสล็อตมีงูมีสลอตด้วยโคอาร่าด้วยนะค
ออสเตรเลียหรือเปล่าโคอาร่าอันนี้ป่า
ออสเตรเลียหรือเปล่าอันนี้ป่าออสเตรเลีย
ในป่ามีหมีใช่มยมีหมีนะคะมีหมีแล้วก็มี
อย่างอื่นมีหอ่ามีอย่างอื่น
แล้วอันนั้นคืออยู่ในป่าแต่ว่ามีสัตว์อีก
อย่างนึงมีสัตว์ที่อยู่ในน้ำสัตว์อะไรคะ
ครูเรียมสัตว์อะไรที่อยู่ในน้ำอืมสัตว์
อะไร
เอ่อเป็นตัวใหญ่ๆอืตัวใหญ่ๆอืๆจระเข้ค่ะ
จระเข้ครูฟ้านึกออกเลยใช่มั้ยนึกออกเลย
ค่ะจระเข้อืมใช่จระเข้ก็อยู่ในน้ำนะคะู้
เรียมอืใช่ค่ะแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นจระเข้
เนี่ยเค้ามีจระเข้ผัวเมียอื
อ๋อสามีภรรยาแต่งงานกันแล้วนะคะแต่งงาน
กันแล้วใช่เาเรียมกดอะไรเนี่ยเรียมกดถูก
อย่างี้เหรอเรียมกดอโอเคนั่นแหละจระเข้
สามีภรรยาหรือว่าจระเข้ผัวเมียอืก็อยู่
ด้วยกันแล้วทีนี้ตัวเมียมีลูกตัวเมียท้อง
ท้อง
ออใช่ท้องแล้วก็เลยแบบรู้สึกอยากกินอ่ะ
อยากกินหัวใจลิงอยากกินหัวใจลิงอ่ะเหรอคะ
เอาไปบาร์บีคิวมั้ยไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไม่ต้อง
บาร์บีคิวโใช่มคะกูฟ้าเคยเห็นคนท้องมยคน
ท้องจะแบบอยาก
กินอยากกินอันนี้อยากกินพิซซ่าอยากกินไก่
ทอดออยากกิน
เฟรนช์ฟรายอยากกินดอกไม้ก็มีค่ะอยากกิน
ต้นไม้อยากกินดอกไม้คว่าเคยเห็นกินอะไร
หลายๆอย่างคนท้องอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนจะอยากกิน
อยากกินกินๆๆเยอะๆแปลกๆก็มีอะไรแปลกๆใช่ๆ
เาเรียกว่าแพ้ท้องมยน่าจะใช่ค่ะอแพ้ท้อง
ก็คือบางคนก็แบบอยากกินกินอะไรหลายๆอย่าง
บางคนก็อ้วกอืก็คือแพ้ท้องบางคนก็รู้สึก
แบบอออไม่มีแรงอื่นอนอืนั่นแหละนะคะเกิด
อะไรขึ้นต่อ
เอจระเข้ที่กำลังท้องอยู่บอกบอกสามีบอก
สามีเ้าบอกว่าอยากกินหัวใจลิงอือยากกิน
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้แล้วจระเข้ที่เป็นสามีทำยัง
ไงจระเข้ที่เป็นสามีก็เลยบอกเอ่อโอเคโอเค
อยากกินใช่มั้ยอืเพราะว่าลิงเ่ะต้องข้าม
แม่น้ำทุกๆวันอยู่แล้วอืมสามีก็เลยบอกว่า
ได้เดี๋ยวจะไปหาหัวใจมาให้นะฮะใช่เป็น
สามีที่ดีมั้ยคะอืมเป็นสามีที่ดีมากค่ะดู
แลภรรยาอือใช่นั่นแหละแล้วจระเข้ก็เลยมา
ตรงนี้
อันนี้
จระเข้มาทำแบบนอนเป็นเหมือนก้อนหินใช่ค่ะ
นักเรียนคือถ้านักเรียนไปที่แม่น้ำเนี่ย
นักเรียนต้องเช็คดีๆนะว่าเป็นก้อนหินหรือ
เป็นจระเข้นะคะเพราะว่าจระเข้เนี่ยเหมือน
ก้อนหินมากเลยอ่ะเวลาอยู่ในน้ำเออหลัง
หรือว่าหัวของจระเข้เนี่ยเวลาดูแล้วเนี่ย
เหมือนก้อนหินนะคะเหมือนก้อนหินเออใช่ๆ
ใช่อืแต่ว่าอย่างที่เราพูดกันว่าลิงตัว
นี้ฉลาดมาก
อือือๆลิงก็ตื่นเช้าใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็ออกไป
ออกไปหากล้วยออกไปหาผลไม้กินอ่าออตอนเย็น
ก็เลยจะกลับเข้าไปในปากอืๆๆอือแต่ก็เห็น
เอ๊ะก้อนหิน
หรอเห็นก้อนหินที่ที่มันดูแปลกไปมแปลกใช่
ครูฟ้าจะจำได้มั้ยว่าก้อนหินที่เหยียบ
อยู่ทุกวันเหยียบแล้วก็เดินผ่านทุกๆวัน
แล้วมันแปลกครูฟ้าจะรู้มั้ยรู้สิถ้าครู
ฟ้าเดินเดินทุกวันเดินๆๆแล้วครูฟ้าเห็น
มันเปลี่ยนไปหรือว่ามันแปลกไปเนี่ยครูฟ้า
จะรู้นะคะว่ามันเปลี่ยนไปอืใช่ลิงตัวนี้
ก็รู้เหมือนกันรู้อืรู้ว่าก้อนหินเนี่ย
ไม่ใช่ก้อนหินเหมือนเดิมใช่มยใช่แล้วก็
รู้ด้วยว่าเป็นจระเข้อืค่ะแล้วทำยังไงต่อ
ลิงทำยังไงต่อลิงก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าเกิดลิง
เดินเหยียบจระเข้เดินๆๆแล้วปึ๊บจระเข้
ต้องกัดลิงแน่ๆเลยใช่ถ้าเหยียบจระเข้
เนี่ยเหยียบจระเข้ก็จะกลัดนะคะใช่แต่ว่า
ลิงจะทำยังไงล่ะลิงว่ายน้ำไม่ได้ครูเรียม
ไม่ได้ค่ะอืลิงฉลาดมากลิงก็เลยแบบพูดบอก
ว่าก้อนหินก้อนหินอืเรียกก้อนหินใช่เรียก
ก้อนหินค่ะจระเข้ก็แบบงงนะจระเข้ก็ะคุย
กับก้อนหินหรอ
อืคุยก้อนหินทำไมใช่มั้เพราะว่าก้อนหิน
พูดได้มยคะครูปาก้อนหินพูดไม่ได้ใชค่ะ
ก้อนหินไม่ใช่สัตว์ก้อนหินไม่ใช่คนใช่ม
ก้อนหินเพูดไม่ได้ใช่จระเข้ก็คิดแบบนั้น
แต่ลิงก็พูดอีกลิงพูดบอกว่าก้อนหินก้อน
หินแล้วทำยังไงกอนหินอทำไมวันนี้ไม่พูด
กับเรา
อ๋อทำไมวันนี้ไม่พูดกับเราแปลว่าทุกวัน
เนี่ยก้อนหินก็จะพูดอือันนั้นคือจระเข้
คิดว่าแสดงว่าลิงพูดกับก้อนหินทุกวันอือื
ออจระเข้ก็เลยแบบจระเข้ก็เลยพูดว่าอะไร
อะไรลิงทำเป็นเหมือนก้อนหินไงอเพราะคิด
ว่าก้อนหินก็พูดกับลิงออืตระเข้ก็เลยบอก
อะไรลิงอืธรรมดาก้อนหินไม่พูดลิงก็เลยรู้
ว่าเออไม่ใช่ก้อนหินจริงๆอออออลก็ลิงก็
เหมือนรู้แล้วว่าอันเนี้ยเป็นจระเข้นะคะ
ไม่ใช่ก้อนหินแล้วลิงทำยังไงต่อคะครู
เรียมลิงลิงก็เลยพูดเลยว่า
จระเข้อืทำอะไรตรงนี้อ้าวลิงรู้แล้วว่า
จระเข้คือจระเข้ใช่จระเข้ทำยังไงอ่ะ
จระเข้ก็เลยพูดพูดไปตรงๆว่าเมียเราน่ะ
กำลังท้องอืมอือยากกินหัวใจลิง
อืมขอหัวใจลิงอย่างงี้เลยหรอใช่แล้วลิง
ให้มยลิงก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคได้แต่เราไม่มี
หัวใจเราก็จะตายนะคะครูเลียม
ใช่ทำยังไงทีนี้จระเข้ก็เลยแบบฮะให้ง่าย
จังแต่ก็โอเคออือลิงก็เลยบอกจระเข้อ่ะอ้า
ปากสิจระเข้เนี่ยอ้าปากใช่แต่ครูฟ้ารู้ม
ว่าเวลาที่จระเข้อ้าปากจระเข้ต้องหลับตา
นะต้องหลับตาด้วยหรอใช่เวลาครูฟ้าอ้าปาก
เนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ต้องหลับตานะคะครูฟ้าลืมตา
ใช่มยใช่ๆแต่จระเข้ต้องหลับลจระเข้ใช่
เลียมก็เพิ่งรู้เลียมอ่านเรื่องเนี้ย
เลียมก็เลยอ๊ออจระเข้อ้าปากจระเข้ต้อง
หลับตา
อืเป็นปกตินะคะเออของจระเข้เนาะใช่่อืก็
็นทีนี้พอจระเข้อ้าปากอือลิงก็เลยเหยียบ
เหยียบหัว
จระเข้เหยียบหัวจระเข้ใช่เหยียบจระเข้เออ
ๆแล้วก็ข้ามแม่น้ำไป
อื
อืใช่ลิงก็ไม่แบบโดนกินแล้วิก็ลิงก็หนีไป
เลยนะคะแล้วบอกหนีใช่ยิงเอ่อยิงลิงก็
เหยียบหัวจระเข้แล้วก็วิ่งหนีออกไปจระเข้
ก็เลยไม่ได้หัวใจลิงอย่างงั้นน่ะเหรอครู
เรี่มไม่ได้ค่ะอืนั่นแหละเค้าก็เลยบอกว่า
อะไรนะคนที่ฉลาดคนที่คิดคิดเก่งๆก็จะแบบ
มีชีวิตรอด
อ๋อก็คือจระเข้เนี่ยก็ไม่ได้หัวใจกลับไป
ให้ภรรยานะคะไม่ได้หัวใจกลับไปให้ภรรยา
แล้วก็จระเข้เนี่ยน่ากลัวใช่มยเพราะว่า
กัดลิงเนี่ยสู้จระเข้ไม่ได้นะคะสู้จระเข้
ไม่ได้จระเข้งับลิงก็ตายแต่ลิงมี IQ  EQ
ที่ดีลิงฉลาดกว่าอืเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยลิงก็
เลยไม่โดนจระเข้กินใช่นั่นแหละอเรื่องนี้
ก็เลยสอนให้รู้ว่าอเราต้องมี IQ  EQ อย่า
เงี้เหรอเราต้องมีความคิดนะคเราต้องคิด
เราจะต้องไม่ใช้เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรไม่ใช้
แบบสู้กันอืไม่ใช้กำลังก็คือมวยไทยนะเธอ
สู้ฉันมาฉันก็สู้กับเธอแต่ให้ใช้ตรงนี้นะ
ใช้เนี่ยคิดใช่เพราะบางทีอ่ะแบบพลังบางคน
ไม่เท่ากันนะอืแล้วถ้าเกิดจะเอาแบบพลัง
ของเราอ่ะถ้าเกิดเราคิดว่ามีพลังอยู่นิด
เดียวแล้วจะไปสู้สู้ตึๆๆๆๆกับคนที่แบบมี
พลังมากกว่าอืเราก็จะแพ้เราจะแพ้ถูกต้อง
แล้วก็ใช้ความคิดดีกว่านะคะใช้ความคิดของ
เราในการคิดทำยังไงให้เราไม่ตายทำยังไง
ให้เราชนะอย่างงี้นะอืใช่ค่ะก็สู้ด้วยอ
สมองด้วยสมองใช่แล้วค่ะเอ่อหมดเวลาหรือ
ยังคะวีดีโอนี้ว่าลืมดำตอนตอนเราคุยกัน
เท่าไหร่อ่ะ 43  3 อยัง 43 เนาะ
43 ก็น่าจะประมาณนี้ 13  17 นาทีเอ้ย
เหลือเหลืออีก 7 เหลืออีก 3 นาทีอ้าเหรอ
เอ้อหมดแล้วนะคะหมดแล้วบวกเลขเก่ง
ครูครูฟ้าถ้าริมต้องใช้ IQ  EQ นะครูฟ้า
คิดว่าริมจะรอดมิมจะไม่ไม่หรอกครูเรียมคน
เราเนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่เก่งบวกลบคูณหาแต่เรา
อาจจะเก่งอย่างอื่นใช่มยนะคะเราอาจจะ
ไอคิวดีเรื่องอื่นก็ได้ครูพก็ไม่เก่ง
mathematic นะคะนักเรียนไม่เก่งเหมือน
กันอืนั่นแหละใช่ฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็เป็นเรื่อง
ที่ดีเนาะที่เราได้รู้ว่าจระเข้ถึงเขา
จะตัวใหญ่อืถึงเขาคจะแบบกัดแล้วก็ตายใช่
มยแต่ถ้าจระเข้ไม่คิดไม่ใช้ความคิดเนี่ย
จระเข้ก็จะแพ้ลิงอยู่ดีนะคะใช่ๆเหมือนเรา
อ่ะที่เป็นคนเราไม่ใช่สัตว์ที่แข็งแรงที่
สุดนะใช่ใช่แต่เราทำไมตอนนี้คนมีคนเต็มไป
หมดเลยเพราว่าคนมีความคิดนะคะแล้วก็มี
สมองสมองคืนี้เนาะซีบัมซีีอะไรนี่แหละ
เยอะเลยเวลาคนเจอจระเข้อือเจอเสือเจอ
สิงโตอือเราก็จะไม่สู้เราก็จะไม่สู้เราจะ
ใช้อย่างอื่นที่เราเพื่อเราจะต้องไม่ตาย
นั่นเองค่ะใช่เพราะว่าเราสู้ด้วยพลังไม่
ได้ใช่ๆนั่นแหละประมาณนี้นะคะวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลาแล้วเนาะครูเรียมหมเวลาแล้วอืใช่ค่ะ
เจอกันใหม่วดีโอต้องเจอกันใหม่ในครั้ง
หน้าแล้วแหละได้เลยค่ะได้เลยจะมีเรื่อง
อะไรมาเล่านะคะแต่ว่าวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อน
วันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะครูฟาสวัสดีค่ะครูเรี่มบ๊ายบาย
โอเค